so hello everybody i am very excited to
be here with rod dreier
rodriguez is a best-selling author he
just finished
uh he just published a book called live
not live not by lies
um and he is also the author of the
bestselling author the benedict option
which many of you might have heard of
but he's also written several other
books rod and i have had some
conversations before
and i was really excited to uh to read
his new book
because i feel like it just puts its
finger right at on the right place in
terms of the
cultural discussion the cultural war and
also a vision of what
is coming towards the future
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
and so rod i have to say i was really
happy to read the book we've had we had
some conversations a little bit before
about your plan for this book
and i was really happy to see how it
came out you know
people don't know this about me but my
wife is from slovakia
and she immigrated when she was uh 11.
her parents left the communist regime
there and her own grandfather who was
actually
in from prague was uh tortured to death
in the in uh communist prisons he was
just a
shop owner that fell you know fell into
the wrong grass and was brought into uh
was tortured in prison and left
was was released just before he died so
that they wouldn't have his body to deal
with
and uh and so to see people
tell this story and to help us
understand how close it is
in history but how close it is even on
the horizon of our of our possibilities
that something like this could happen to
us again for me was i was really
grateful to see it and i was grateful to
see you weave in
just all the right people uh you know to
re weave in dostoevsky and
kundera as well i was really happy to
see you weave some of the threads
that he puts out and so tell us a little
bit about what
was the impetus what what it is that
really kind of drove you to write this
at this moment
yeah it's it's astonishing to hear that
your wife is from slovakia
this by the way is a country that i
never thought about at all
until i happened to go to bratislava to
an ideas festival
and my host introduced me to people who
have been part of the underground church
and
as you know i ended up dedicating the
book to
a priest by the tomas love kolakovic who
had prepared the slovak church
underground church for this persecution
and i i really think
that uh we are in a kolakovic moment in
this country maybe we can talk about it
later
anyway the impetus with the book
jonathan was um a phone call i got
back in 2015 from a physician
in the at the mayo clinic here in the
u.s
his mother was living with an elderly
mother she was an immigrant from
czechoslovakia
she had spent i think four years in a
communist prison for practicing her
catholic faith
and uh was eventually released came to
america and married her fa
his father and uh the old woman was
saying son the things i'm seeing happen
in this country now remind me of what it
was like under communism when it first
came to my country and it scared
the physician you know and he just he
reached out to me because
he one of his patients was a friend of
mine and he wanted to tell a journalist
so i thought that was really kind of out
there you know
america is like communism come on but
the more i started talking
to people in this country who had come
from communism
uh whether it was russia or one of the
other eastern european countries
the more began to realize that they were
onto something and
if you talk to them at length they would
get really angry that americans just
don't take them seriously
solchenitsen said uh in the gulag
archipelago that one of the biggest
mistakes we can make is to think that
what happened in russia
can't happen here he said it can happen
at any country in the world given the
right set of circumstances
so what i did with this book is i i
took their alarm seriously i started to
the first part of the book is about
explaining what it is they're seeing
precisely that reminds them of communism
it's not stalinism 2.0 but it's
it is the total politicization of
society
and that is the essence of
totalitarianism part two of the book is
practical advice from people in those
countries christians
mostly who had been dissidents i i asked
them what do we need to know
now here in north america to prepare and
that's the book
yeah and i really it was interesting
that you right away at the beginning
let's say differentiate uh a
dictatorship from a totalitarian state
and it's important because it helps us
understand how the totalitarian
the totalitarian state can actually
creep in on us without there being a
dictatorship yet because it ends up
taking ends up infecting our minds and
ends up creating
let's say totalizing spaces of what is
acceptable
and what is it acceptable to think or to
talk about and then methods
of finding weeding out people who think
differently
and actually excluding them from society
in really radical ways and you mentioned
some of those
some of the people that have lost their
bank accounts and it's still just a
handful of people
and it's people that we would still
maybe think are despicable uh people who
lost their bank accounts are not allowed
to use paypal
a lot of not allowed to engage in
society but the fact that the mechanisms
exist
is already a frightening a frightening
prospect for the future
yeah it really is and i i think jonathan
that
the fact that our idea of
totalitarianism when we think of that we
think maybe of nazism or we think of
stalinism
we think of gulags secret police that
sort of thing official censorship
from the state we don't have that in
this country
and or in north america and your country
and so we think that it must not be
totalitarianism
augusto del noche is uh one of the great
political theorists of the 20th century
in italian
and he pointed out that the essence of
totalitarianism is the politicization of
all aspects of society and therefore
it can exist in a capitalist liberal
democracy
that's what we're seeing happen here and
it's coming
so fast i mean the the letters i get
from people every day not only
you know people from within academia but
also within corporations who
are talking about how suddenly this
ideology is arriving out of nowhere and
they're terrified to say what's on their
mind they don't know
you know when they're going to step on a
land mine um
and the fact that people just so many of
us north americans just
are walking through life thinking that
oh this is not a problem or
um this is something on the right that a
problem we have on the right
they think that if we just elect the
right politician that's going to solve
the problem
it's not no it is really is a creeping
up of a totalizing
uh totalizing way of thinking and so
there have been some
even to me there have been some alarming
signs in the past few years of course
four years ago there was the kind of
jordan peterson moment who he warned us
about this coming because he could see
it in the universities
and now we're seeing it you know it's
only four years later and of course the
election cycle
isn't is accelerating this because it
seems as if you know because it's a
crisis and people
are afraid of what's going to happen in
the future the process is accelerating
but during this election cycle the fact
that we saw journalists like
glenn greenwald and matthew clasius quit
their own publications to
to go freelance because they were
feeling censorship within
their organization these are not like
right-wing people these are
just kind of regular liberal types and
it's
it's it's accelerating and we just see
it people don't
they see the individuals it happens to
individuals it happens to individuals
and this is of course the problem is
that as it creeps in and it kind of
becomes a pattern there are even things
right now that
people everybody knows that if you say
certain things at work you could lose
your job if you say
certain political ideas at work you
could lose your job and we've almost
accepted that as
normal we all accept it as if this is
this is a normal thing but it's not a
normal thing
no no it's not and this is the you know
the proverbial frog and the pot of
boiling water
that is exactly what's happening and
what's interesting too is when you talk
to young people like millennials
uh and gen z especially they have been
raised in
an atmosphere in which this is normal
and i i just um about i guess it was
last month i went down here in louisiana
where i live it's pretty conservative
part of the us
i went down to give a talk at a state
university down on
bayou lafourche now this is deep cajun
country
it's really conservative uh and i i'm
just giving a talk about my book live
not by lives
a few days before i arrived there was a
huge controversy on campus
some members of the college republicans
had chalk on the sidewalk there
trump 2020 maga right completely
ordinary stuff this caused such an
uproar the social justice warriors on
campus they had a three-hour student
government meeting
it ended up where the head of the stude
of the college republicans and his
girlfriend
had to go had to be escorted by campus
police to class because of death threats
now here's what's so interesting about
that this was not in
overland and this was not at berkeley
this was at nicholls state university in
south louisiana
and i i went to college here in south
louisiana back in the 1980s and i was
more or less on the left in
college the idea that we would have
appealed to authority
to silence our opponents uh much less
make death threats against them
would have been completely unthinkable
but now it's happening and it's
happening
as i said not just in super liberal
parts of the country
but here in really conservative parts
and what will also accelerate and it
seems inevitable
that it will accelerate this pattern or
the the fear and the
the frenetic energy to bring about this
system is
that those people that wanted that made
death threats against someone who wrote
trump 2020 on the sidewalk
now have to deal with the fact that that
50
of the voting population at least near
50 of the voting population
voted for this person that you are
afraid to even see his name written
on us on the sidewalk so so in their
perception like this isn't this is an
evil they have to defeat like this this
is an absolute evil that they have to
defeat and
things line up politically for them even
though trump is barely is not a
conservative he
he's he's actually quite liberal in
terms of his
his own values but he they just it just
lines up in terms of a narrative
and so everybody and i i i've talked to
even someone very close to me
who said who talked about how you know
the trump supporters and trump is
anti-lgbt and i was like
trump is not anti-lgbt like where did he
even get that like there are pictures of
him holding a pride flag
it's like it's like but it's just
because they line it up right they just
line it up on the line and it all falls
in place
and that's scary because it's it is it's
a narrative thing that's going on
well you're right and this is one of the
things that i think is key to
understanding what's happening now
a lot of people think of the social
justice movement as
a political movement deep down it's a
religious movement
uh when i studied the bolsheviks and how
they came to power and what they were
about
that became so clear to me jonathan i um
you know they they couldn't get any
traction in russia in the 19th century
until the uh the 1890s there was a
terrible famine in russia and the
tsarist regime
did a very poor job handling it that
event was a triggering event that caused
a lot of the middle class to think maybe
these marxists are right
and the marxists had been the bolsters
have been preparing for that moment when
the czar exiled them all to siberia
it was actually kind of admirable what
they did they came they weren't living
in jail they were like living in exile
colonies
they came together to study their holy
scripture marx ingalls
and to talk about what they were going
to do they were willing to suffer
for what they believed and and because
they were willing to suffer
they had a certain cachet and a certain
authority
when they came back into mainstream
society in the early part of the 20th
century
and they started evangelizing the
factories in the factories of russia
you had so many because russia was
starting to industrialize in a big way
you had so many peasants uh men mostly
who had come out of the villages
and they were disconnected from their
families they were disconnected from
their churches and everything that gave
them
a sense of structure in the world and
because of that the they were desperate
for something to give their life a sense
of meaning
and there were the bolsheviks preaching
marxism i think we're
in we're in a very similar situation now
and so many of these young people
who have been alienated from the church
alienated from institutions in our
society
they are susceptible to this
totalitarian movement that gives them a
sense of
purpose a sense of meaning and a sense
of solidarity with
others their age and we see in the
manifestation of the
of these groups the religious elements
and they're not they're not you don't
have to look very far to notice
that a lot of the protests which
happened uh you know during cobit after
the death of george floyd
were religious in nature you know they
were
using uh sacred iconography they would
even
represent him with halos with a with
wings and uh
the people were kneeling they were even
self-flagellating i saw people
actually whipping themselves and so
they're there and the washing feet and
there so there was and there was it was
like this catharsis of
of course it was exacerbated by the fact
that we had been kept apart it was
almost like
we were we were fasting during the first
part of kovid
and then all of a sudden this event
happened this like death of someone
happened
it was almost like a mock easter and
everybody joined came into the street
to process and to to to to cry and to
celebrate
you know this thing which united them
which is totally understandable it's
like i
i understand it but there's something in
it which is obviously
it's off-key and it's a it's this is
what i keep trying to help people
understand that the kind of normal
liberal is freaked out to see
how religious these manifestations are
and they're saying no i thought we're
supposed to get rid of this religion
thing
but you can't you just cannot it just
will keep coming back you have to be
deliberate about it not accidental about
it
well you know one of the key moments in
in our recent history
that that revealed it was an apocalyptic
moment that revealed what's really going
on here
came in 2015 in the fall of 2015 at yale
university
you might recall that there was this big
controversy over halloween costumes
erica christakis she and her husband
nicholas both yale professors and uh
masters they don't call them that
anymore
the masters are like house parents at
silliman college
she sent out a note to the student
saying you know yale is telling us that
you better be careful what kind of
costumes you wear at halloween
um because you don't want to offend
anybody but erica christaka said
you're grown-ups you know come on this
is this is ridiculous
the students jumped on her and her
husband
for um for being racist and not caring
about them and hurting them
because they they rejected this
authoritarianism from the college
that there's this great moment captured
on the internet where nicholas christoph
is her husband these are baby boomer
liberals
he goes out into the yard at silliman
college and tries to engage
this woke mob in reason discourse
about the issue they don't want to talk
about it
you can see them shrieking at him and
cursing and
wailing like this man is a heretic
reason is completely impossible with him
and of course the yale administration
collapsed uh and and gave in to the mob
uh erica christakis ended up leaving the
university
this is an important thing for people to
understand that uh
this is not about reason we're dealing
with religious fanatics
yuri slickem who is a russian american
historian
he wrote this great book in 2017 called
the house of government about the
bolshevik revolution
and he describes the bolsheviks as an
apocalyptic
millenarian political cult you know and
and he goes and talks about the
religious aspect and it's
so interesting to see the parallels
between them
the bolsheviks and our social justice
warriors
in particular the bolsheviks saw good
and evil
as going the lavatory good and evil
going right down the middle between
social classes peasants workers good
bourgeois bourgeoisie the wealthy
aristocrats evil
and it was the sheep and the goats and
there was an apocalyptic
bloodletting there that is what i'm
seeing
happen now when you see and every day
are somebody right and sends me
more more data about this where you see
the line between good and evil being
being
laid down between races and identity
groups
and i i cannot imagine anything good is
going to come out of this
yeah because it's dealing with
identities that you can't change like
in terms of let's say a christian ideal
where you move
into the church and you enter into the
into salvation there's
at least a door for you to kind of
advance where here there isn't
what's interesting about the halloween
example is just
how perfect it is to manifest the
totalizing aspect
one of the things i've been telling
people about is helping them understand
these inversion festivals
and how there are festivals in all
cultures
that manifest a a breakdown of order and
an upside down
aspect to them and halloween is one of
them that we have where
you dress up as monsters you dress up as
ghouls there's there's this whole
kind of becoming a monster becoming an
exception and manifesting the exception
and so it's it's in those like the the
king's fool or
all of these uh they had feast of the
fools in the middle ages all of these
festivals are there
to point to where the system breaks down
and it's important to keep that you need
to have places that point to you where
the system is in total
and so the fact that they would attack
that place
is perfect in terms of showing how they
want to totalize
and it's also the the attack on humor as
well right you can't tell certain jokes
you can't
all the places that are there to poke at
the system are being attacked
by a totalizing system so it's
interesting to notice and to
to see that it's happening there first
and then it's going to start to grow and
take over
because like you know totally there's
always this saying that
you know the totalitarian can't handle a
joke can't handle humor because
there's no room for it right because
irony
is not possible in a totalitarian
society and uh you know i
we were told when trump won in 2016
we were told and i think it's true that
a lot of people voted for him because he
was against political correctness
um and it seemed almost trite at the
time when i remember hearing that but i
the the more we went on the more i began
came to believe that's true
trump was the only way that a lot of
people could
could flip the middle finger to the
ruling class
and uh whether it was wise or not to
choose him as
the avatar of rejection of them is
another question
but there's no doubt that you know he
was
it yeah yeah so i want to i want to
shift gears a little bit because
one of the things i don't want to talk
about the problem the whole time is
what's wonderful about your book is that
you also propose some solutions to
the the question one of my favorite
chapters in the book is the one where
you talk about
about memory and then the need to
participate
in communities at different levels of
reality
and so you you do point to the church as
being the highest version of this but
you also
point to all different levels of places
where we can
come together and join to to manifest a
a group a kind of a common purpose a
common goal and something which is
extremely
connected to our daily lives so maybe
you can tell us a little bit about that
sure one of the the people one of the
families i feature in
live not by lies is the benda family of
prague
they're catholics they the late vatslav
benda
spent four years in prison for his human
rights work
uh and uh they were the only catholics
only christians in the inner circle of
bots love hovel and the charter 77
dissidents back in and under communism
and i i interviewed them about the
the their modes of resistance they're in
their apartment
in prague they have this great apartment
tall
ceilings i mean this is the eastern
european intellectual apartment
books everywhere it's messy it's just
wonderful
camilla bendava the widow of botswab she
still lives there
she welcomed me into her house with some
of her adult children and just because i
wanted to find out what is it like for
an ordinary family
to deal with this all we read about
usually is the demonstrations on the
street uh
that sort of thing but how do you raise
a family of resistors people who not
only
know how to resist the political
oppression but who know how
in their in their lives to be faithful
to their religion in a very atheist uh
country well one thing they did there
and roger scrutin
was part of this when he would go over
there uh during under communism got
arrested for it in fact
they would hold seminars where they
thought it was so important to bring
people together uh to talk about
literature to talk about art to talk
about history
because all the stuff being taught in
the schools was bunk it was ideological
garbage people went to those seminars
and
in apartments like the bendas and there
were others so they could remember who
they were
what it meant to be a check what it
meant to be a christian what it meant to
be part of the west
the communist regime depended on erasing
that memory from the minds of the people
so they could be molded
that was a big part of the resistance
botswana bender also talked about
something he called the parallel polis
he said that the communists depended on
complete atomization
of the population and and making people
afraid of each other
for control so what benda tried to do
was just bring people together
for non-political things like picnics
anything to get people
to come out of their houses and realize
that they are part of a community
um and so that was something as
simple as having a picnic or having a
lecture about
art was a political act there to try to
rebuild a sense of community
another thing that the benders did was
to show
films they showed a high noon for
example that was a big one in their
family
because they they wanted to demonstrate
to their children and to others this is
how a brave
a brave man behaves you know like gary
cooper in that film
and in this way art and telling stories
uh reading literature to the kids that
it was
it was important that you not only point
outside the house and say this is where
the evil is but you also give
their children and people who are lost
and
build up their inner uh their moral
imagination camilla told me that
she would read to her kids two hours
every night even though she was working
right and her husband was in prison she
still read to them said what did you
read she said i read myths i read the
classics
i read a lot of talking why tolkien i
said
she looked at me straight in the eye and
said because we knew that mordor was
real
right and and to this day uh 30 years
after the fall of communism
in one of the most atheist countries in
europe all the adult bended children are
still practicing catholics and so are
their children
yeah it's pretty amazing i was really i
mean i think that one of the great
things about the book and i really
recommend everybody
reading it is both inspiring and
humbling
you know to be inspired by these
characters and humbled by the fact that
you know how much they're willing to put
into this and how much energy
and will and also how it paid off like
you said that despite their suffering
despite people people dying people being
imprisoned
you can see this this kind of spark of
life and
continuing on and in their generations
and one of the problems that you point
out in the book which is
which is real for us is that we seem the
system that is coming towards us seems
to be a strange
um it seemed impossible but a strange
mixture between
1994 and a brave new world at the same
time it's as if
we have these systems of total
surveillance which are appearing on the
line and also
mechanisms of exclusion uh and of total
marginalization but at the same time
we have this decadent society of of
pleasure
and of fanciful you know whatever
fanciful thing you can imagine has more
weight than
let's say normal family normal society
right
so it's hard to deal with because it's
not the same thing so how do we answer
this
this because it makes us lazy right we
don't have it's not as
we don't have an easy target to kind of
say we're going to resist against that
we have netflix and
porn and and things kind of dropping in
on us that just make us lazy and uh
oh my gosh yeah just this week i had uh
coffee with a man
an evangelical protestant who does a lot
of ministry with
youth and and he was saying to me we
were sitting there having coffee and he
had just discovered my book live not by
lies and was
amazed by it and wanted to talk about it
and he said he held up his phone he goes
this this is the the problem and he
talked about the kids are so obsessed
with their phones and their xboxes and
their
social media blah blah blah and yet he
gives
his kids access to it all and i i just
couldn't the cognitive dissonance there
i couldn't figure out because
i for what i understood from talking to
him and this is a good man
right who cares about kids who is
engaged with the youth
is that it seems so overwhelming to him
that it's best just to
let it happen and just hope your kids do
do well with it
camilla bendava the the woman i was just
talking about
i remember sitting in her apartment in
prague and notice that she had a
dumb phone on her coffee table i asked
her about that i said why don't you have
a smartphone
and she said that if you've lived
through what we have lived through in
this country
you know that there is no way that
information can be collected about you
uh
innocently and of course she knows as as
we all know or should know
that companies are constantly collecting
information data about us and building
profiles to sell us things
well camilla said sooner or later this
is going to be weaponized
against us that's why i talk about the
book how i think what's coming here is
something as an american version of the
social credit system that
china uses it is perfectly compatible
with a capitalist society right but
they have the the the ability to control
people and manipulate people
is greater than even mao zedong and
stalin had
it is actually possible in china to
cut people off from the economy
completely because they don't they're
moving to a cashless society
you do all your um you're buying and
selling with your phone
i talked to a guy in nashville the other
day who an american who said
yeah it was amazing to me to get toilet
paper in a public toilet you have to use
your phone to pay for it
if the government decides to cut you off
you're done
it really is a matter of you can't buy
or sell unless you have the mark of
approval from the government
now this is coming here too but we don't
see it because
it makes this technology makes our lives
convenient
yeah and also because there is this
strange
it's a strange place where because it's
happening
mostly through corporations rather than
through government for now
the it's disarms the right leaning
people
it disarms the conservatives because
they're all libertarians and so because
of that
they have no weapon to tell google
or to tell twitter they their only
answer is to say well don't use their
platform right
that's the capitalist answer and the and
it's it's like okay well
i don't see how this is going to get
better but it's tough like i i suffer
with that baptist pastor because
our kids had no phones and no almost no
access to the internet
until covid yeah and then
they had then for months they were alone
and
they couldn't go anywhere and we
couldn't go anywhere and we were we were
in total lockdown and they couldn't see
their friends and they couldn't
and so they and then the school said
well they need to have
a phone or else they can't go to school
so they we did school online and so
since then
we've had the exact problem the phone
has taken over
yeah now we're like what do we how do we
deal with this because
without a phone the kids don't have
friends it's like it's a it's a
it's a scary scary place we did the same
thing with xbox with our teenage son we
didn't have any of that in the house but
because of covet i mean it was really
really hard for them
and for him especially um and so yeah
you have to make some compromises and
i'm not i'm not sitting on my high horse
criticizing this pastor so much
uh you know our kids we're a little
tougher on them with the phones but
look i mean i've got a phone i'm on the
internet all the time
but uh ultimately this is undermining
our liberties and i'll tell you
something else too in the book i talk
about this conversation i had with
a young hungarian maybe she's 29 30
years old she was my translator and
uh budapest we were on the trim
going to one of the these interviews and
she was talking to me about how
difficult she finds it uh
as a young married person and a young
mom
to have conversations with her friends
she said as soon as i tell them that
you know my husband and i are having
some problems or boy it's just
exhausting
raising my kid because they cut me off
and they they say oh just put your kid
in daycare leave your husband go back to
the workplace
you be you you do do what you need to do
for yourself
she said i want to tell them no no no
i'm happy being married i'm happy
being a mom a stay-at-home mom but um
but it's difficult
but they don't under she said they don't
understand
the importance of suffering they don't
understand even mild suffering the kind
of suffering that all of us do is we're
getting used to being married getting
used to being a parent
she said they have been so um
acculturated
to the idea that anything that gives you
anxiety or is hard
should be pushed away and run away from
and rearrange your whole life to avoid
any kind of suffering or anxiety and i
looked at her and said it sounds like
you're fighting for the right to be
unhappy
she said that's it that's it where did
you get that well i pulled out
my phone and went to chapter 17 of brave
new world
where the the the guy the savage yeah
john savage
john the savage yeah he is uh unlike in
1984
when winston smith meets o'brien the
torture or o'brien is like really
giving torturing him to make him conform
uh mustafa man the world controller in
brave new world
he said to uh john the savage why do you
want to stay on the outside of our
society you can have
so much pleasure you have christianity
without tears that's what he says
and john the savage chooses suffering
because it's real
it's real life well this is why the this
revolution that we've gone through
in the last 50 years and that is
accelerating is so
hard to resist because we have to choose
to be unhappy or in other words to
choose the the
the conditions under which unhappiness
is possible suffering is possible
because it's real
those who would want to control us are
offering us
you know no suffering at all yeah but it
it
it's a trick because we see and we just
have to look around us that people
are miserable and that people who try to
avoid suffering
end up taking you know pills to fight
depression they
they just end up wandering meaninglessly
and
and accumulating stuff and being
miserable whereas people
you and you know them people who have
kind of taken up
a hard life to take care of someone
who's sick who who
who have lost a child and have kind of
dealt with it in a
in a healthy way you can see that they
come out of it shining
that they have a brightness about them
that we don't see very often anymore
and you know i have to tell you that
under covid you know it was really tough
for us
at first your listeners may may not know
that i'm an orthodox christian and
uh we here in louisiana
we couldn't go to liturgy for a while
and i i got really fed up with that and
a lot of christians were too like why
we're not doing this you know
but then i had to stop and think about
the people i just spent
time talking to who couldn't go to
church because if they went to church
they would be thrown in prison or
christians who were thrown in prison
they still had to hold on to the faith
even though they were suffering
vastly worse than than any of us were
simply by
being told we couldn't go to church and
i had to fall back on
the things they said about learning how
not to feel sorry for yourself because
if you felt sorry for yourself then you
were done
and not to hate their torturers i mean
this is
incredible the testimonies some orthodox
christians from catholics or protestants
who went through that it was possible to
be broken by that experience but if you
were willing to offer your sufferings to
christ and suffer as a christian
then it would refine you i tell the
story and live not by lies
about this uh slovak photographer teemo
krishna
uh who was uh raised in the fir he's the
first generation after communism in
slovakia
and uh he had freedom and success and
material uh
wealth that his parents generation could
only have dreamed of
but he still wasn't happy he decided to
go do a project a photo
photographic project of interviewing
elderly people who had
been political prisoners for their
catholic faith
under communism and he said that
just being with these people some of
them are still quite poor
today and to talk to them about what
they went through and how
even in prison those are some of the
most joyful times of their life because
they knew they learned to be close to
god in ways they wouldn't have
understood before
it changed timo's life entirely and he
realized that
he that wealth and liberty
can be a prison too yeah and
it's interesting because i've had my
moments during the because we are still
in a kind of semi lockdown
there are some churches that have small
liturgies you have to reserve in advance
you have to wear a mask and there are
other churches that just don't have it
at all
um and so to be honest i haven't been to
church since the beginning of copen
because then
they opened lockdown opened up for a few
weeks and locked down again and
it's just been very frustrating and so
i've had these moments where i
kind of feel that frustration but then i
i i think that reading your book also
helped me to
to ask myself okay well then if i'm so
frustrated this and i'm frustrated at
this stage because they want to prevent
me from doing this
like am i getting up in the morning am i
doing litany's am i reading the psalms
am i
like no i'm not i'm a lazy you know it's
like i'm doing my barely my morning
prayers
and then it's like i go on with my life
but if i really did care about this and
i was really suffering
that i'm not in communion in church then
i would be compensating for it in my
daily
prayer life but i'm not and so it is
more this kind of
just laziness and easily blaming you
know
this this but i i still think that that
all of this
at some point is going to have to end
but i think that it has to start
with my own discipline rather than
wanting the state to change their rules
right now
exactly and this is why i really do
believe that kova that god has
allowed this to happen as sort of a
severe mercy for us
to prepare us for what's coming in the
future
you know if we as christians whether
you're orthodox or whatever if
if you can't handle this sort of
deprivation
uh without falling apart or losing your
discipline
or you know just being filled with anger
then
you're not going to make it through
what's coming that's one thing that i i
have really a lesson i've tried to take
to heart
through all this that uh don't don't
look at it don't get angry
from covet i mean we're all sick of it
maybe we're
angry at the government angry at our
bishops whatever and that might be
justified
but that anger is going to destroy us
if we hold on to it and we don't we
don't instead
um use this time in this trial
to deepen our repentance and deepen our
conversion i'm just like you
i'm i have not been uh not added
more more prayer disciplines you know
and it's
it's so stupid because i i know where
this is going but it's really it's a
matter of the will
less about the mind than about the heart
and so i'm curious though because the
book came out i imagine
that you were finishing up editing it as
kobe was kind of coming in and so you do
mention it a little bit in the book but
it's not it's not like a pervasive thing
in the
in the narrative and so have you seen
because one of the things that people
are perceiving and i have to admit that
it's hard for me not to perceive it a
little bit
especially now with certain language
being used you know this idea of the
great reset and
certain phrases that are used by all
world world leaders at the same time
uh and so there is a sense that somehow
kovid
is at the least an opportunity to
accelerate this system of control
and that we're that it's going to happen
faster because of this
this pandemic i don't know if that's
something that you've meditated on
yeah i i think it's true um and the the
difficult thing here is
realizing that the pandemic is real you
know it's not like
they've invented this just so they could
can figure out how to control us
but i i think they are using the the
fact of the pandemic
as an opportunity it's like their
reichstag fire right
and um i i think that one thing i've
noticed here where i live in baton rouge
is that most places i go now they prefer
that you use
the the card the debit card to pay for
little things things that you would
before hand over cash well it's
it's safer it really is to use the card
but we get accustomed to that and
whenever you make a purchase with a card
uh that data of what you bought is saved
yeah and so a profile is created of you
by these companies by these banks what's
going to happen
when the workstars in who are running
these banks decide that
as they've done in england you mentioned
earlier that your politics are so
appalling that
they're not going to allow you to have
an account
with them well go find another bank what
happens when they all decide that
and what happens when uh no stores will
take
cash anymore i mean this is a trial run
for this sort of thing and also contact
tracing
it makes perfect sense to do contact
tracing this is how you fight a pandemic
but at the same time you know what
happens when they start seeing
the fact that you're a christian or
you're a conservative are you in some
way or part of the deplorable
community and they want to contact trace
where you've been no i it seems like at
least
the mechanisms are there and it's it's
even though it's not happening now it's
just a question of time before someone
starts to use these same mechanisms to
trace people for political reasons and
we know it's true
because we are watching the companies
that are using the data
becoming politicized at this very moment
they are
they are politicized and they're acting
more and more in terms of
politics taking political stances taking
uh
value and ideological stances and so
there's
as this accelerates it's going to become
more and more of a reality
yeah and here's what's so interesting in
china the social credit system there
you would think the chinese people would
be appalled by it by the fact that the
government
government computers are are using this
data to give everybody a social credit
rating and if you
do things that offend the government you
get a lower rating and your privileges
are reduced
you think they would all hate that it's
not true
a lot of them love it because communism
uh the experience of communism uh
destroyed social trust there
and a lot of chinese people just don't
know who they can trust their society
has been
so and so much turmoil as capitalism has
taken over
uh that uh they feel like they're gonna
be taken advantage of at every turn
so if you look at a social credit rating
you know that person with a high rating
is trustworthy
it gives them a sense of security to
have the social credit system
similarly in this country i think
especially with the millennials and the
gen z who becomes are becoming more
politicized culturally
they're going to look at this as some as
a tool that helps them
stay pure and not do business with the
bad people yeah and i think they're
going to welcome it
uh james polos the cultural critic he
had he says that we are headed to what
he calls
a pink police state uh what he means by
that
is that we will be a people who will
sacrifice important political liberties
like freedom of religion freedom of
speech
in exchange for safety and health which
is to say
a society in which the state guarantees
that we're never going to be troubled by
by people who believe destructive things
and things that make us feel unsafe
and they will continue to give us our
porn give us our pot
make this stuff available to us uh the
only price is going to be the
surrender of political liberty and polo
says that this is coming that people are
going to welcome it
yeah and it's to me it's it's a strange
fascination because i remember when i
was young i was kind of in uh i grew up
in a
evangelical culture and apocalyptic
culture there was a lot of that stuff
going on
and i remember as a young person reading
to being told about the mark of the
beast and thinking
why would anybody accept that like why
would a society like i i
i was trying to figure out like okay so
there's this thing this mark and then
people are identified and then they if
they don't have it they can't
participate and i kept thinking
okay but why would anybody accept that
like how could it happen in a society
and it's just been
very strange to watch it happen and to
kind of watch
the idea that we that this notion of of
being identified
and being let's say man not managed but
being identified as pure being
identified as as part of the system
is something which we are actually
welcoming quite quite easily
and it's a weird upside down thing too
because
the the thing that will make you
excluded in the end
is you not being open
so it's actually it's actually you have
to ex to you have to
accept completely those that are
supposedly excluded
in order to be part of the system and if
you have some kind of hierarchy
then like any kind of hierarchy then
you're going to be excluded that's what
it seems to be yeah yeah you know hannah
aaron the uh
the great 20th century political
theorist she wrote a book called the
origins of totalitarianism and she was a
refugee a jewish refugee from nazi
germany but
she set out after the end of the second
world war to understand why it was
that germany and russia had both
surrendered to totalitarianism though
very different systems
and one of the things she found was that
in both countries the elites were
willing to
surrender and allow the the the pillars
of civilization
to be destroyed for the sake of allowing
those who had been excluded in the past
to come in we see that happening right
now especially in our universities
you know the idea of diversity and
inclusion
these are just words used to
as a cover uh for destroying the things
that make a university
a university destroying the ability
to have freedom of thought freedom of
expression within the university to
debate ideas
yeah now if you bring up if you
contradict uh
anything with this new ideology then
you're being accused of being against
diversity and against
inclusion and you are therefore a
heretic yeah
and so one of the things that has been
one of my motivating factors in the past
few years
has been to help people understand
marginality
and to understand it in both positive
and negative
sense because the two aspects of the
totalizing systems
let's say the fascist system and the
communist system it's a caricature but
the two sides of the total totalizing
system is that one of them
wants to cut off the margin completely
to remove it burn it
right and the other one wants to include
it completely
in a way that it is normalized and both
of those
are just the wrong they're just the the
danger of not letting the margin be the
margin
right not letting the fringe flop in the
wind like not letting
the edge of the carpet have uh tassels
and uh the idea that if you read in
scripture it talks about leaving the
corner of the fields on
uh you know that that aren't you don't
reap the corner of the fields or that
you leave
the the fringe on the vestment you need
a fringe on your vestment and so
this or the the narthex the gargoyles on
the outside there's all these images of
of the fringe in in a traditional
society and carnivals are part of it and
all this
and i'm trying to help people understand
that
someone's someone mentioned this on on
twitter and tagged me on it said
that we often think that it's dangerous
to bring the dragon into the city
because of the city that it'll destroy
the city but we don't think
how dangerous it is to bring it into the
city for the dragon
because for a dragon to remain a dragon
it has to stay outside the city
and some aspects of society are have
power in their marginality
like they have a they have an effect on
the world because they are
questioning the system so the fool
you need the fool to stay the fool but
if you start saying stop saying that the
fool is a fool
and stop saying that he's a fool he's
just like you he's like well yeah but
the fool is part of
this you need the fool to act like a
fool and to be the fool
and to have the advantages and
disadvantages that come with it
right yeah in the orthodox tradition as
you know we have the holy fool that
comes out of russian orthodoxy
where uh people learn to pay attention
to the fool they don't try to
domesticate him they don't try to
you know bring him in and make him
respectable they
they listen to his voice because he's a
prophet
yeah and that's that's exactly the right
way is to say that the fool has to
remain
raw if you try to domesticate the fool
you're damaging you're you're damaging
the system and you're going to damage
the fool
on on both sides you know just before we
came on to this uh this interview
i saw on twitter that the muir woods out
north of san francisco it's an
incredible place it's a redwood forest
i've been there it is like
you go there and you understand where
the druids came from
right that you could see why you would
want to worship trees yeah
but they they now have a thing they put
up there the park service talking about
mirror woods queer woods they talk about
queer ecology
and the forest and it's the craziest
thing it is the most
blatant example of trying to uh force
this ideology
into places where it doesn't belong it
reminded me jonathan
of um what happened i talked about this
and live not by lies too about
uh the after the soviet revolution the
bolshevik revolution
the soviet chess society was trying
really hard to keep politics
out of chess to make it a pure place
where we just came there for the game
and they put out a statement saying we
want to keep chess for chess's sake
well accommosar wrote to them and said
no no no comrades after the revolution
everything must be
brought in under the umbrella of the
revolution we can't have chess for
chess's sake
that is a mentality that is so
destructive
of everything and we're doing it here
now the idea that the
that the freaking mural woods is now has
to be queered
oh man i wish they would have gone to
the end of their making chess
uh communist and then made all the parts
move the same
yeah then see how far that goes in terms
of maintaining your chess club
you know it's nothing against lgbt folks
but the idea that
you have to bring this woke
consciousness whether it's
race or sexuality to just walking in the
woods you can't walk in the woods and
clear your mind and
get away from the revolution the
revolution is
always with you now i would feel the
same way if
this were 50 60 years ago and they were
putting patriotic propaganda there and
trying to make the woods
uh a testimony to the greatness of
america
it's just the woods have to be the woods
yeah especially the wild spaces
especially
those untouched spaces that are they
actually represent
the idea of non-civilization or non
id they say they're now an analogical to
non-ideological because they're not
there they're left wild like the corners
of the field they're like so just leave
them wild you don't have to
you don't have to constantly uh yeah you
don't have to colonize
it's it's interesting because it's
actually a way of it's a kind of reverse
colonization of nature like a form of
colonization but done from
from the from a certain ideological
perspective and you know
when i was in poland last year in warsaw
doing reporting for this book
i talked to polls two or three polls who
work for
the polish branch of western that is
american and european multinationals
and they were talking about the cultural
imperialism that is coming into the
polish workspace
from big business for specifically they
were being compelled to participate in
lgbt pride celebrations even though they
were catholics and this violated their
conscience
but they said that it's so hard to get
jobs this good here
or our families are struggling what
should we do and
it made me really angry as an american
that
this is that these people they had to
suffer colonization by the soviet union
and now
they're suffering colonization by you
know colonization
by world capitalism i mean it's just
anyway sorry i mean it's but it's a it's
a i think it's good to understand the
moment and it's also
for me it's good to see the upside down
moment because
it's as if that which is marginal is
trying to become
king and trying to then impose its its
weird kind of marginal identity on
everything but and so that's why
in your book what's wonderful about the
book and what's wonderful
about the possibility at this moment is
to actually take the dissident position
and so one of the the kind of
fascinating double ironies of your book
is that
you use uh that kind of early russian
style
on the cover of the book where you're
you're actually using this
yeah because i have the audio book so i
i don't have a copy of it
and so you're using this kind of early
modernist style which was revolutionary
to now talk about resistance and
dissidence to
this new system and and it's a i like
pointing to the robin hood story
like this weird robin hood moment where
everything becomes upside down
and the illegitimate becomes legitimate
and so
then the normal person ends up looking
like a rebel and ends up looking like a
like a dissident and
the babylon bee does a lot of that on
that where they talk about the
rebellious
family that decides to stay married and
have kids and how they're totally
flaunting the rules of society you know
uh and so there's a position to take
which is actually uh
which is a consistent position which
which also has some motivational power
in in knowing you're kind of a strange
upside-down rebel
just by being normal yeah yeah the cover
is it is soviet constructivism i i
deliberately chose that design
to be uh to flip things because as you
say that was the artistic style
associated with the revolution
well i wanted to make christians uh
christian dissidents out to be
like revolutionaries uh and there are
some older
people i've heard in orthodox parishes
in the u.s
who are really bothered by that because
it is associated with communism but uh
i can understand that but i'm trying to
flip things as you say in
an ironic way um i i think that for me
as an orthodox christian it has been
helpful because if you are an orthodox
christian in north america
you are on the fringe by definition you
know and it has been
really good for me uh to accustom me
to being an outsider uh and to
be okay with that living in that outside
space because it's going to have be more
and more the case that not just for
orthodox christians but for
any christian or any traditionalist you
are going to be
already on the outside but increasingly
persecuted for being on the outside
but we have so much in recent church
life in the life of the church in the
20th century
of that persecution and sure and showing
that it's possible
knowing from lived experience that it is
possible
to survive it yeah well listen i
i first of all i really appreciate this
conversation and i want to encourage
everybody to get live not by lies
uh you know you can get i listened to it
on audiobook twice while i was carving
and so there are different ways you can
get the book it's definitely worth it it
is both humbling and encouraging
um and it gives us some solutions little
solutions to
put in place as we kind of move into
this strange
uh soft totalitarian space so thanks rod
for
talking to me oh it's my pleasure and i
want to end jonathan by simply saying
that
this is not an optimistic book but it's
a hopeful book
what's the difference optimists believe
that everything's always going to be
great
don't worry about it well that's not
really true that's not realistic
things may work out well but they may
not we may have to go to the gulag
but people who are hopeful believe that
in the
end good will triumph god will triumph
and we may not live to see it but as
long as we unite our sufferings and stay
faithful and even if it cost us then
we will be part of the redemption of the
world that god works
so hope christian hope is the thing we
need
not false optimism all right thanks rod
it was great to talk to you
great talking to you too so if you
enjoyed my discussion with rodrigo make
sure to check out his book
live not by lies a manual for christian
dissidents
there are also several ways you can get
involved in the discussion
about the symbolic world we have a
facebook group
there is a blog a multi-user blog where
several people
are interpreting different aspects of
reality using symbolism
we also have a clips channel which
breaks down many of my talks
into smaller subjects there are also
several ways you can support the channel
by checking out some of the products we
are designing using symbolic imagery
and also going to the symbolicworld.com
support
supporters get one patron
supporter only video a month also the
chance to ask questions in advance of
the q
a and hired heroes also can participate
in small seminars on symbolism and have
private conversations with me
during the year so everybody thank you
for your support we've got a lot more
coming in the future and i will talk to
you very soon